yo guys what is up in his prestige mldg
here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel video and the new DLC and
final DLC is out the clap tastic voyage
and open ball hunter pack 2 is out and
this is the final boss fight for that
dlc if you do not want to have any
spoilers obviously don't watch this so
in the end shout trap go straight crazy
betrays you fuses himself with the H
core I think it is and becomes this
giant robot now that is called eclipse
this giant robot will shoots electricity
balls at you like dead lifted he'll
shoot a projectile missiles missiles at
you like a like constructors do and he
also has kind of like doss lasers they
should are really fast and slower just
beam lasers that you saw now I found a
pretty good way to fight him which is to
go up on I left maybe the rights of the
map from the center stage and there be
little the kind of like a kind of look
like smokestacks but cylinders that have
jump pads at the bottom of them that
push you up you can go up and down in
these jump pads just stay on the jump
pad repeatedly you'll see a little bit
throughout the video and he won't be
able to inflict major damage on you as
always you can shoot the rockets and the
electricity balls and they'll explode
before coming contacting you but other
weapons you're gonna have to have
something in front of you or dodge you
won't be able to shoot it out and this
is a really good method because you can
go up and down through the thing and
shoot him when you're at the top and
bottom parts and like say if he's if you
need to regen health you can just go up
and down really quickly so you never go
to the top so you never have that delay
tile the top you will need to run around
and get ammo since it is very ammo
intensive it is a slow way to kill them
because the crit spots are only at the
top of his head which is pretty small
and the large portion of his back but
his back it does not face you often and
there's going to always be like two one
two three little minions that around you
that are going to be available to
get yourself up on in this boss fight
which is something I really like also um
wasn't gonna say I just forgot it what
was it was about about yeah yeah the
down system I went down a lot during
this fight and I did not notice at any
time my fight for my life getting
substantially shortened so that even if
I went down a lot I would get as long as
I killed an enemy um i would get back up
I didn't have to worry about a huge
amount of I didn't have to worry he's
amount about dying instantaneously once
I went down as you can see there are
these volatile bits that are either
health or corrosive if you shoot them
when they're corrosive they'll spew out
little corrosion that'll go attack
enemies so if he's close to you then
shoot him with hit those crows of things
he's corroded I believe he takes extra
crows and damage because he is an all
armor boss and so yeah that's pretty
good well overall I think this fight
with the clips is a pretty good one it
took a really long time for me because i
use the i use that trick that I showed
you for most of the fight and because it
is a much safer way to fight him this
way you can go around him you can get
more ammo and you can hit his a back
crit spot a lot more however it does
leave you a lot more open to getting
killed and I wasn't able I was thinking
about just doing this whole fight how i
did it and just giving that to guys not
making like a commentary on it however i
do not have the sound without not mixed
with other sound because i was talking
to people while i did this dlc so you
get their voices I don't know you guys
don't really want that that's going to
be basically it for this video this is a
long fight it's a fun fight and it's the
final boss fight you can see I kill them
there however there is a little bit of a
twist and I'm going to be making a
second video on that probably putting
them out the day after I put out this
video so if you want to see that be on
the lookout